a friend of mine passed away who was you
know one of the most important parts of
nine oh two one oh and that was Luke
Perry and um I think for me I just kind
of felt like it was honoring him and his
memory there are moments when it's
easier than others
you know what I I still haven't thought
I think people are are curious about
that how how you will enter weave is a
memory we can't do this show without
mentioning that and then dealing with it
in some way it's really still so so
fresh it's hard to reconcile a world you
know it's still struggling with that
loss to everybody that's ever met him or
knew him he was he was an amazing person
and he was a blessing for people to have
in their lives
Luke's untimely passing will be
addressed in the first of this revivals
six episodes we're told it will be a
tasteful tribute to a beloved friend
fitting since it's that kind of bond
that reunited this cast after almost 20
years Jenny and I wanted to work
together we were best friends ever since
the show so we would best friends for 30
years we've raised our kids together our
out-of-control girl
we're like 9:02 a now and really mmm I
don't know
no one will ever do that and then we're
like wait but what we did it a different
way
what if it wasn't a straight reboot we
were first on the set of this not so
straight reboot that has the cast
playing heightened versions of
themselves the scripted drama blends
details of their real lives with their
characters to me it's exciting to watch
the show and did for yourself figure out
what's real what's not we should do this
for real what do you say you'll be king
Kelly and Donna and David and Brandon
and everyone as you think you want to
see them but only older so it might
freak people out or people freak me out
full disclosure this set is a lot bigger
and a lot nicer and yeah the Peach Pit
gets a full-on update to expect to see
lots of references to the original
series cuz some things just shouldn't
change this is my Brandon Walsh hair
didn't your daughter put on a 91 Oh
t-shirt like Kelly Taylor
they had a 90s themed dance at her
school so she put on a Beverly Hills
90210 shirt and she went as Kelly Taylor
oh my god they were projecting a
mid-1990s images on the wall and never
images from nada - and pictures of me
and I was like I gotta go I gotta go
you
[Applause]
[Music]